bonsoir arrive à nagoya merci de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
les premiers cas de variants découverte
donc sur le territoire guyanais liés à
la proximité avec le brésil
quel est l'état d'esprit ambiant à
cayenne ben c'est l'incertitude
l'inquiétude j'imagine non même pas en
fait ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que ces
quatre variants sans rentrer sur le
territoire par l'aéroport en fait un
félix éboué
donc ils viennent tous les quatre de
paris et même pas du brésil pour le coup
parce que nous avons en fait à ce jour
encore des restrictions très importantes
sur le territoire on a une frontière à
l'intérieur du pays même dans la commune
de saint georges où justement fait en
est censé faire le filtre entre la
population qui pourrait arriver du
brésil et celles qui pourraient venir de
guyane et aller vers le brésil
donc on va dire que là où on t'attendait
que justement peut-être viendraient ces
variants du brésil quand ils viennent de
notre aéroport félix éboué de paris
alors qu'on est censé avoir des tests
pcr avant de prendre l'avion pour la
guyane et qu'on est censé avoir aussi
une certaine
donc qu'est ce que vous dénoncez en en
expliquant cela en fait aujourd'hui ce
qui nous pose problème c'est que la
population est empêché de circuler
depuis un an quand même pour ce qui est
du couvre-feu en guyane et que depuis
c'est un an là nous ce que nous pouvons
constater c'est que le virus fait sa vie
en fait il fait ses va-et-vient ça monte
ça descend tout en ayant un couvre feu
qui n'a jamais cessé qui n'est jamais
parti alors pour justement faire face à
une un pic
parce qu'on a eu un pic en janvier qui
n'est pas la seconde vague pour vous la
population qui en fait un pic
parce que du coup on a eu vingt mille
départs en congés norman de fin d'année
on a beaucoup de fonctionnaires sur le
territoire ou de personnes tout court
qui vont se balader et donc 10 pouces et
20000 la retournant les a pas gérer et
on a laissé le virus rentrée sur notre
territoire puisque à ce moment là il n'y
avait pas les tests pcr exigé à l'entrée
du territoire et ensuite on nous dit
le effectivement le virus circule et en
du coup on coupe tout tout tout
circulation à la population en tuent
l'économie guyanaise depuis un an quand
même depuis 1o nous les restaurateurs
jamais une envers un camp parfois jamais
ils n'ont pu ouvrir on va dire sur toute
l'amplitude possible sachant que c'est
le soir que se font beaucoup de que
l'activité ton est en fait en guyane on
ne voit pas en nous on ne se voit pas
sortir de cette crise alors que la crise
elle fait ses va et vient aujourd'hui on
est en dessous du seuil
dallaire il faut le savoir sur le nombre
de cas en guyane à peine une trentaine
par semaine et pourtant on est en
restriction majeure sans notre
territoire avec des contrôles partout
donc ils fonctionnent vraisemblablement
entre le brésil et la guyane
mais il ne fonctionne pas entre paris et
la guyane
et ça c'est bien dommage en tous les cas
les variantes sont donc rentrés s'ils ne
sont pas rentrés par le brésil comme
vous dites mais par la métropole par
avion comment est-ce qu'il faut réagir
maintenant face à ces variants sachant
que ces concerts se fait d'ailleurs dans
l'hexagone
maintenant il faut rapidement tracé
isolé tout à fait en fait le collectif
justement mayouri centennial demande
il a été créé dès avril les premiers cas
c'était en mars nous avions cinq cas sur
notre territoire et on disait attention
nous la guyane de par des jalles
insuffisances au niveau sanitaire
on a à peine quinze lits de réanimation
qui se passe donc qui se battent en duel
pour une population de 300 milles estimé
donc derrière on faisait attention et
aujourd'hui c'est pareil pour le variant
on sait qu'on a quatre cas de variants
on sait que potentiellement il ya des
cas contacts à ces variants donc il est
urgent d'identifier les personnes de les
isoler et d'éviter que justement cela se
propage dans la population puisque
vraisemblablement les verrous ont bien
pour fonctionner au tour mais on voit
qu'en fait plutôt que de se donner les
moyens matériels et humains au niveau
sanitaire plus de docteur à moment donné
on nous avait annoncé 250 médecins qui
devrait renforcer les hôpitaux de guyane
en attend toujours
on nous avait demandé aux néo ont
interdit que des lits
animations et des lits d'hospitalisation
viendrait en attend toujours aujourd'hui
on parle aujourd'hui d'un chu en guyane
la guyane quand même c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui qu'on l'a découverte et
c'est un territoire français donc voilà
aujourd'hui en fait on se pose des
questions parce qu'il est beaucoup plus
facile pour certains de restreindre la
circulation de la population que de se
doter en moyens humains et matériels
sanitaires pour faire face à un virus
que quand même aujourd'hui depuis un an
elle sur notre territoire et qu'on
devrait pouvoir réussir à vivre avec en
fait nous voudrions vivent avec
vous avez évoqué les chiffres 15 lits
pour trois cent mille habitants en
guyane hormis la menace des variantes
quelle est la situation générale en
guyane quid de la pression hospitalière
notamment en ce moment même oui tout à
fait parce que on a quand même quand
même aujourd'hui l'hypertension des
problèmes vasculaires qui ont toujours
existé en guyane qu'on n'a jamais pu
réussir à résoudre on va dire en termes
d'accompagnement sanitaires on a
toujours avec nous le problème de
coriaces à nos maladies tropicales 1
avec les moustiques donc derrière
aujourd'hui on a des on al'impression la
dengue
je voulais parler de la dengue excusez
moi et donc du coup on a des maladies
qui d'ailleurs la dengue a les mêmes
symptômes que aujourd'hui le coc vite
quand même donc on se rend compte qu'on
ne nous parle plus de la dengue
alors qu'ils ont les mêmes symptômes et
que du coup en fait voilà il a une
question à se poser est la vraie
question c'est que contestent les moyens
vous rappeler à l'époque j'étais
intervenu parce qu'on avait demandé un
hôpital de campagne en avait en avait un
pic où il y avait une trentaine de
personnes en réanimation est aujourd'hui
bon c'est perdu ses moyens là sont
partis ils sont partis alors que on doit
soit on doit soit disant faire face à
une seconde du salaire qu'on répondre à
ma question quelle est elle en soi même
en guyane
bah justement pour l'instant l'hôpital
tiens on tient le les hôpitaux tienne ne
tienne comment dire ça tienne le coup
mais on n'est pas prêt face à un pic en
fait on est prêt pour faire face à
aujourd'hui aucune affluence
et heureusement que derrière comme je
vous le disais la pression héros
descendue côté qu'ovide il ya moins de
cas et même les cas d'hospitalisation
finalement ne restait pas longtemps et
ne faisait pas non plus des normes cas
de réanimation ni deux ni des normes cas
de décès heureusement mais derrière
aujourd'hui si on doit faire face
invariants brésiliens ou que ou que
sais-je
on n'est pas prêt il n'y a pas ce qu'il
faut sur les territoires aux moyens
humains et techniques merci va nouveau à
la voix répondu à la question je
rappelle que vous êtes la porte parole
du collectif améliorer santé guyane